one two three and I am in Washington DC
to attend the American Library
Association's annual conference Hank
this conference is kind of the highlight
of the young adult literature social
calendar you get to hang out with like
thirty thousand librarians which is
awesome because librarians are the
secret superheroes of America plus I get
to meet all these authors I like like
Nina Lacour and the ladies behind
beautiful creatures and Lauren all of
her and Mary rosewood and noted unicorn
apologist diana peterfreund so here's
what I did today first I went to a panel
I wasn't on then I went to a panel I was
on with David Levithan and I was all
like how do we use the internet to lure
readers that sounds like then I talked
to my editor Julie Straus Gable about my
new book do you like it love it
have you finished it yeah why haven't
you finished it I don't love it
do you think it's gonna be my next book
for sure yes tell the nerdfighters what
it's about desert islands and very
dangerously attractive boy boots up to
know that fair I think he's up to a lot
of good he thinks he's a lot of good
like men often do any girl girl narrator
we like the girl narrator and then we
went to the actual conference where
there are just so many books all over
this conference there are advanced
readers copies of hundreds of books and
you can just take them new Cassandra
Clare won't have all right so John here
we are nobody's around it's gossip booth
so all right either I can give you an
early copy of Mockingjay or I can give
you
Natalie Stanford's awesome confessions
of the Sullivan sister Standiford okay
okay good choice hey lest they be
murdered by marauding fangirls I am
excited for the new Natalie Standiford
book but Mockingjay wasn't really there
also if you don't like books they got
other schwag like this gavel that is
also a pen which is good because then
you can be like I hereby declare it time
to write all right Hank I'm gonna go
hang out with some librarians but I'll
see you on Monday